as we continue to follow joe biden's
approval rating decline recently uh and
his accomplishments
and as we continue to close in on the
start of the 2022 midterm election it's
hard to deny that the the biggest
political question in terms of the next
six to seven years of american politics
is the question of whether donald trump
will run for president in 2024
we can pretend that there are other
bigger questions because we would like
to believe that the question of trump is
over but it's not the case trump won
under unusual political circumstances in
2016 and then lost
under a relatively rare situation in
2020 where an incumbent president loses
reelection that it's that's not a common
thing it happened eight or ten times in
american politics but
typically when presidents run for
re-election they win
trump's base seems as committed as ever
to him he's been doing rallies he says
he's going to soon be doing rallies and
key election states like iowa and over
the weekend we heard from not one but
two trump insiders his former strategist
jason miller and perpetual brown-nosing
republican congressman trump suck-up jim
jordan we heard from both of them
trump is almost certainly running in
2024
um and jim jordan even saying he's about
to announce any day so let's get right
into the clips here is jason miller
appearing on a channel or show called
cheddar news
says that the odds are 99 or 100 percent
that donald trump runs in 2024. what's
the likelihood president trump runs
again in 2024
i would say somewhere between 99 and 100
uh i think he's definitely running in
2024. i had a good conversation with him
last night i'm gonna go see him another
couple days here uh he has not said the
magical words uh to me but
if you talk to him for a few minutes
it's pretty clear that he's running and
i think the just what we've seen unfold
in afghanistan recently has really just
uh emboldened that so that's jason
miller and then congressman jim jordan
says trump is quote about ready to
announce this is video once again from
lauren windsor she's been doing great
work in this video lauren pretends to be
a republican
and uh check out what jim jordan says
and we're going to have it from two
angles for you here
[Music]
he's going to run again so
i know so okay i talked to him yesterday
he's not ready to announce after all
this greatness in afghanistan thank god
yeah like environment
yeah department
he's really
so jordan says trump's going to run
again i know it i just talked to him
yesterday he's about ready to announce
now they could both be wrong
they could both be knowingly lying
because there's been a decision made
that it's good strategy for someone to
claim that donald trump is is running or
likely running even when he isn't i
don't know
but more and more things are pointing
that way for sure now as i've said
before
i know that this is horrifying in terms
of what it means for the country but if
donald trump does run and is the
republican nominee in 2024
he has a really good shot at winning
based on
what's going on today things can change
but based on what's going on today
i don't know that i see joe biden
defeating trump in a rematch this is not
you know people will write to me they'll
say david you're you're poisoning the
well now i just tell you things the way
i see them right now i don't know that i
see biden defeating trump in a rematch
if biden doesn't run and it's kamala as
i've outlined before i don't know that i
see kamala defeating donald trump this
is just me being real and of course us
knowing this and getting together around
it could prevent it from happening but
my preference is to soundly defeat
trumpists in the midterms
so that trump hopefully sees
this is not looking good for me all of
my strongest followers or many have been
defeated and chooses not to run to avoid
the embarrassment of another loss if we
think of 2022 as a sort of referendum on
trumpism
and all of them lose you know matt gates
jim jordan marjorie taylor green
beaubert hawthorne they likely won't all
lose but if a bunch of them lose
that might be the signal that convinces
donald trump not to run so is jim jordan
a known liar and he might be lying here
of course sure is jason miller a known
liar absolutely it his uh professional
and personal life from what we've what
we've heard
but lots of signs point to trump running
now here's the counterpoint
when i was on michael cohen's show
michael cohen of course trump's former
lawyer michael cohen said he doesn't
think trump runs in order to avoid the
shame of losing again but that's sort of
what i'm saying also
if trump becomes convinced that he will
lose
i don't think trump will run i think we
just don't know that yet in the sense
that the 2022 midterms are going to be
our signal about whether trump is likely
to do well in 2024 or not either way
i believe that if donald trump runs
the gop won't stand in his way in terms
of the primary you'll have some
challenges but they won't be serious and
the party won't get behind the
challengers
but a disastrous 2022 for trumpism
may be what gets trump to say you know
what
i'm not going to get involved because
the risk of humiliation is too high let
me know what you think you can find me
on twitter at deepakman
let's be honest most healthy snack bars
are not exciting like my live streams
and that's why you should check out our
sponsor monk pack monk pack keto nut and
seed bars
are sweet and delicious soft and chewy
with a big satisfying crunch but each
bar has just one gram of sugar two to
three net carbs and just 150 calories so
it's great for someone on a keto or low
carb diet or even if you just want a
tasty sweet snack without the sugar
monk pack keto nut and seed bars come in
great flavors like sea salt dark
chocolate
caramel sea salt or caramel you choose
and peanut butter dark chocolate i
always have a box of these ready to go
in my pantry
which is easy when you do the optional
monthly subscription which also saves
you 10 percent if you have a sweet tooth
this is the way to indulge without the
guilt whether it's for breakfast or in
the car or after a workout go to
monkpack.com the link is under this
video and you'll save 20
when you use code pacman at checkout